uh it's a new year we have got a lot of
work to do let it let it ride everybody
likes marcus mariota he's a nice guy
we've interviewed him we like him but at
some point you got to perform i just
have not seen enough you know as far as
just pure quarterback play for me to go
oh marcus mariota's the future and the
titans are in good hands we finished the
season nine and seven wasn't good enough
so i would say that there's a lot of
areas that were just
a little better than average
we say from time to time that we're in a
golden age of young quarterbacks in the
nfl the problem is that window opened in
2016 because in 2015 the top two picks
were jameis winston and marcus mariota
they're both still with their original
teams entering the final year of their
rookie deals but neither guy has proven
himself worthy of that second contract
and both guys really in a prove it or
else year with the titans and the
buccaneers and story number 28 as we
look at the top 30 storylines entering
the 2019 season chris can marcus mariota
make the most of what as a practical
matter is his last chance in tennessee
we've seen it for four years the
consistency isn't there the injuries are
there and will he be there after this
season what he does this season is going
to have a lot to do with whether or not
he sticks around yeah i mean it
definitely is you said it it's a make or
break here uh marcus mariota has shown
us glimmers you know certain stretches
of seasons and games where we go oh okay
they got it he's the franchise
quarterback this looks good but then you
know he'll have a few weeks in a row
where
you know things sputter and as far as
his accuracy decision making taking care
of the football has been an issue with
marcus mariota and jameis winston oddly
enough with them being the one and two
pick uh but yeah it's really about him
just continuing to refine the position
the quarterback we know he's an athlete
but can he raise his level of
decision-making accuracy you know
accuracy down the field um just being
able to truly dissect a defense with the
pass game that is what we have not seen
from marcus mariota the guy you know the
guy like hey can he be surgical and
we've seen moments of it to go oh i
think he can but then there's you know a
few games in a row where we go oh man
that's not surgical at all that's a
disaster and that doesn't look good and
then he gets hurt on top of it so big
questions this year he's got to stay
healthy to prove himself there to the
tennessee titans franchise he's got to
stay healthy too mike because ryan
tannehill's there and he's a pretty
talented quarterback too and very
similar to mariota to where i think
he'll be breathing down mariota's neck
if he does go down for a few weeks and
with an injury
yeah this is not blaine gabbard this is
a guy who has shown that he can play
well when healthy i know some dolphins
fans will be spitting their coffee out
at the suggestion that ryan tannehill
actually is capable of playing well but
he is he had he had the team in position
to make the playoffs in 2016 and they
did even though he wasn't there for the
last few games of the season right
that's how good they were when he was
playing if he's healthy he can be
effective and he's a far better option
than what they've had in the past and
that's where mariarda needs to be
concerned because we talked about this
the other day on pftot he's gotten a
mandate from general manager john
robinson to avoid contact live to play
another day right and if you don't do
what you're told that's one of the
factors in whether or not they're going
to keep you the guy who is responsible
for putting the roster together has told
marcus mariota in no uncertain terms
avoid taking hits avoid getting yourself
injured so if he fails that's going to
be a negative as they decide what to do
and you know what if he gets injured hey
let's see what ryan tannehill has maybe
he's the guy that we rally around for
2020 and beyond you know it's not easy
to find a quarterback but the thing is
with a marcus mariota what do you do
with a guy who's making 20 million this
year and he's going to be a free agent
next year what do you do now maybe you
keep him chris because nobody else is
going to pay him either but i don't know
that this is what the titans were
expecting i know this isn't what they
were expecting they're expecting a
franchise quarterback they made him the
second overall pick and he hasn't been
yet no you're right he hasn't been yet
and then you know again to defend marcus
mariot a little too has there been a
great support system around him as far
as you know
high level uh talent at the wide
receiver position and the running game
and hey matt lafleur it was his first
year calling plays last year and
everything i think we saw the potential
but i don't think we all saw it and went
oh man that was like the greatest show
on turf wow what plays what game design
all that no i think lefleur was growing
as well in year one there but now it's
back to like scratch with a guy like
arthur smith who's never done it on the
offensive side of the ball but i'll say
this with mariota i do think he's got
more talent around him than years past
with hey getting roger saffold and free
agency at the guard position they were
weak in the interior part of the o-line
last year and then hey a guy like corey
davis is coming along maybe not as good
as they had liked but adam humphries at
wide receiver and free agency hopefully
delaney walker's healthy to where hey he
should have some weapons at his disposal
and the run game finally got going last
year mike and they need to lean on that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports